President Trump plans an important
address today on the deadly opioid
epidemic that killed nearly 50,000
Americans last year but the speech will
not include a promise declaration after
pledging for months to formally label
the epidemic a national emergency he's
scaling back a White House official
confirms the president will name the
opioid crisis a public health emergency
and that is a less sweeping declaration
that the president had suggested earlier
major Garrett is at the White House with
the latest on this story major good
morning good morning the president had a
choice national emergency or public
health emergency the first is usually
linked to hurricanes other big natural
disasters the second typically linked to
infectious diseases we last declared one
in 2009 to combat swine flu both
declarations and visions short-term
intervention and requires specific
congressional funding the president's
announcement comes amid his argument
that he is not supervising a Republican
Party deeply divided the opioid is a
tremendous emergency six states have
declared opioid emergencies and now the
federal government will follow suit the
goal reduce addiction to prescription
pain medication or drugs like heroin and
fentanyl we're going to be doing a very
very important meeting sometime in the
very short very near future or opioids
the president months ago backed forty
five billion dollars in new opioid
spending as part of Obamacare repeal but
that bill died due to GOP divides and
new divisions now confront the president
we have actually great unity in the
Republican Party mr. Trump told
reporters his party is unshaken by these
broad sides none of this is normal his
political model and governing model is
to divide if senators Jeff Flake and bob
corker defect on tax cuts this top White
House agenda item could be in jeopardy
we want tax cuts for the middle class we
won
tax cuts for businesses to produce jobs
there's great unity the president
predicted flake and corker will fall in
line mr. Trump also said flakes decision
not to seek reelection showed he was
weak his poll numbers are terrible he's
done terribly for the great people of
Arizona and he would have never won an
exasperated Ted Cruz compared the
criticism of the president to middle
school I really don't care who passed a
note to the cute girls and pigtails
everyone shut up and do your job
House Republicans are struggling to
write that tax cut bill and the lead
author Texas congressman Kevin Brady is
clashing with the president over
tax-free contributions to 401k accounts
earlier this week the president said
those accounts were off limits now
Charlie he says it's up for negotiation
details details details thanks major